stop talking over the today's Masters of
the Universe
especially Gilbert dan Murrow on there
is Daniel Radford we're gonna be talking
about the thought process behind our
writing and our thinking and all the
wasted time we spent he man messes the
universe flattened we'll be kicking it
to some deleted scenes that didn't make
it into the final cut and then we'll be
responding to viewers like you
y'all we watched this movie it was dumb
but I feel like it kind of got a few of
you in your nostalgia bones sure I'm a
little bit that again I is one that like
I definitely I had already seen he-man
and Shera and so I do remember this
movie and I remembered Courtney Cox
weirdly enough I remember her being in
the movie and the whole thing about her
parents I did always as a kid think it
was really funny that pmn was just
running around shirtless so yeah that
got me a little bit yeah and Dan this is
a this is a bucket list one for you this
was I want to thank you all for
indulging my list for like any time
there was a hole in the schedule and it
made even a slight amount of sense to do
message the universe I would always ask
if we could do masters in the universe
we never could yeah
so literally this time I think I may
have partially pitched the idea of walk
Buster summer just yeah I mean I love
this movie why why do you love this
movie Dan it's a mix of the fact that it
is so bad and so stupid at the same time
I was four years old when it came out so
I've seen it 50 times least and I loved
he-man I loved the cartoon so this weird
movie is also a part of my DNA yeah I
haven't memorized it's it's like I
remember everything about it and so it's
just that weird combination of just like
I I get it but at the same time like it
was like this was a labor of love
because I have to put you on the spot
but you do some pretty good impressions
from the film give us in itself longer
and saying grilled or well this is my
favorite thing is even before we did
this trailer I'll just go and then give
us a little grill door and then wow this
is I'm sad Joe's not here laughs he
lasted scoops McGee short but then I'll
just just like mostly it's a little bit
of will Ferrell doing Harry Carey but
just Billy Barty and that weird
character that's not Orko but was
obviously supposed to be Orko I mean if
someone came along I don't quite have
the same relationship cuz my older
brother was a big he-man fan he's five
years old of the me and I I like was
more Ninja Turtles that was my action
finger multi media tie-in beyond chives
so watching this I'm just like this is
some type of money-laundering scam most
Canon films it's like we need to have
some kind of thing that we can put out
just to say and then like take a loss on
it and to like sell all this bootleg
you know polo merchandise that's
interesting because my sister is five
years older than me and I think it's
just like I really wanted to be my
sister so everything she liked I liked I
loved Hot Wheels I loved he-man I loved
all that stuff just because she liked it
this is a there's a very specific window
for this movie it may be as short as six
months just like in this almost exact
exact bullseye for it to like share
anything other than just like not
knowing about it
right or hating it this was one of the
first times I distinctly recall ever
being disappointed by a movie I think
moment Anakin I think it was like 9 or
10 in every movie I'd ever see
especially in the theater like going to
the theater was still like a treat and I
was just into being in a movie theater
and this was one of the first times
where I remember watching movie in the
theater and still being like wait do I
not like this is this disappointing
what's happening to me Sebastian the
universe was your first moment of real
disappoints like a real existential
crisis movie for nine-year-old me I mean
I still I still like I didn't hate it
like you it they got a certain cheating
a movie is an adult like I was still
into it I just still like I recognize
that it wasn't really doing it for I
think that I think for me at four or
five whenever the aware although is in
the air so the reason that I loved the
entire movie was because Skeletor was
awesome and I think Skeletor was so good
mmm
that it made the rest of the movie
amazing for me because there's not a
much he-man I mean right there
everything a he-man was cool it was
really cool to see a big guy with the
sword even though he was firing guns and
I using the sword he did say I have the
power but Skeletor is so cool and scary
that I think that that justified the
entire movies existence and it had the
guy from back to the future
that made me laugh what you're four or
five years old like I do think that was
the first time I was like that's not how
it is in the cartoon like that was big
like introduction to Canon that's right
I mean because this was also from an era
where you wouldn't know anything about
the movie before you see it it's like
there's a trailer there's they're making
a movie is out I'm gonna go see it and
so I didn't know the movies not set in
Eternia it's not gonna be like the
cartoon until I'm not for Adam he's just
always yeah yeah like when you're
watching you're like are they gonna
spend the whole time in the parking lot
outside this chicken restaurant we gonna
get somewhere you know swords and
sorcery little above a chick they still
chicken and ribs okay you're right your
eyes say they'll read alright let's see
what other animal parts they got into
trailer for Humanity mess in the
universe this summer we're getting
honest about summer blockbusters past
and present this is honest trailers
Blockbuster summer have we been sued by
blockbuster yet
no we changed the telephone
nice I'll so come on fortress they're
blockbusters there's wine GI Joe and
before the inevitable funkopop Moo and
they're making it what if it's kind of
based on action figures that's also the
kinkiest terrible movie based on action
figures if you notice right there and we
did get to point this out he definitely
winces before anime and whip on the
animators cuz it's not like I'm not ever
a real whip to react to I hope not
I'm not like Dolph Lundgren's an idiot
I'm just like they didn't they didn't
get the timing exactly right yeah almost
well can you explain to the audience a
little bit about Cannon Films Wow yes
the makers of this are notoriously
frugal what'd we say I mean this was you
could do this in the seventies you can't
really do this anymore because all of
the IP is locked down by major media
conglomerates and they want to keep the
rights to do their own streaming shows
Arobin yeah they would go and obtain
various IP and then they would sort of
produce the movies on the cheap and hope
that the name recognition would kind of
put them over yeah and you know seize it
for quite some times it worked very well
and yeah I mean like it was it was a
viable I mean the the thing people
always come back to is like Superman
like it seems unfathomable that an
independent film company would be making
Superman movies but the studio's didn't
really think there was a ton of value in
those kinds of props superheroes are for
children right there was like you know
it's gonna be expensive and who's gonna
even go see that at some newspaper strip
you know Yeah right about that one yes
so you know like so yeah we used to be
possible to be these kind of like
maverick independent film producers who
just kind of raised the capital
themselves and operated outside of the
studio system we're able to do this and
we do a wide variety of all sorts of
crazy weird bizarre movies I mean if you
look up the history of canon and these
guys Golan and Globus they made a ton of
crazies I thought I always liked to talk
about is the disco musical the apple
from today amazing oh my god it's like
one of the great how does this exist
bizarre because it's got a whole
originals like a full original musical
like original songs
Tesla called how does this exist the
four of us could be on it I'm sure it's
nobody's ever done anything like that
sounds unique alright let's keep playing
yeah that's trailer for low to the safe
word is Cringer masters obeys counter
burgers prints out of scale 15 minutes
Katherine oh yes in peril and only
he-man can save it in this adventure for
colleagues together all your favorite
heroes from the Masters of the Universe
car to pause except if we go back go
back
no you have the Allan very artfully
hidden screen behind that rock yeah you
can hear him faintly so people saying oh
you should put an Allen in here in
between all the grille doors we did put
an Allen derriere he's behind that rock
the obvious no they're hard to find now
you have to earn it
plus it like that Hidden Mickeys at
Disneyland yeah alright keep going
universe cartoon except for Battlecat
cirrostratus ramen zonocorp man-e-faces
oh come on not even Orko I would have
been too old or blue and hanging from
the ceiling but at least your favorite
villains are here like this butter
carving of skeletal human beast man
pause why not use the toy characters
like if you've bought the rights from
what I read is very complicated a very
complicated negotiation with Mattel
because he man started as toys yeah and
and why from what I read one of the
things that the they that entailed was
that Mattel said that none of the
canonical human characters could be
killed and so if you made the football
lizard Merman for example that means you
couldn't kill him and they do end up
killing him however it is funny because
that character they did end up making an
action figure of even though he's the
one that they killed the movie so beast
man is a Skeletor henchman but the other
ones aren't because they wanted a little
more license with how they can what they
could do with the character nothing
which they did nothing nice it's so
strange because then they don't really
like you didn't need to kill them it
wasn't like a huge plot point that blade
adds to die gets knocked out and then
it's fine you can use their recognizable
character like I feel like as a kid this
was a real deal breaker kind of thing
for me well yeah I mean it would have
been nice to see some yeah you're going
hoping to see the characters that you
know and love and instead you get this
motley crew of whatever they had left
over from like Capricorn Ones costume
maybe they were hoping it wouldn't be
noticed because just half the film is
encased in darkness and lit from the
back bright takes place like behind a
diner
my favorite is kargh because he's got
the bouffant hair yes yes he has the
crazy lizard type face they're here you
can't really see the neck he's wearing
like a fur shawl he's like if Karl
Lagerfeld was like I know he's like he's
the bad guy that had the queer eye
makeover he's got like a throw on like I
guess it's a little cold in the throne
room it's a big room I'm sure they got
the AC blasting he's he's fabulous
everyone is fully clothed
it's like piccolo got hit with an acid
attack good anyways yeah they couldn't
get trapped y'all in there he's easily
as dumb as football wizard I mean come
on all your favorite tea man locations
like the majestic throne room of Castle
Grayskull set and wait that's it or is
this whole thing gonna be about Courtney
Cox's dead parents it's my fault a guy's
plane crash
things just happen unless that plane
crashed in the snake mountain I don't
care love Dolph Lundgren has Ivan Drago
and monkey pus we got a little drags
because we've said Draco Drago sorry
sorry well sorry we said Treecko did he
say he said Drago yeah yeah no no no
that's right I did not I did not notice
it when we were watching the cut I
apologize sorry I know it's Rocco no
brother sorry about that
yeah well oops that's why we have this
no you do the show now yeah so we cannot
have wrong here is Ivan Drago in rocky
for now witness this invincible
Superman's greatest weakness having to
talk now why are you so important to
Skeletor let her go
don't be afraid I won't hurt you I don't
was phonetic I mean we're giving him
crap but like English is not his first
language and he's so much smarter Oh was
it MIT he is a master's degree from the
inner city of Sydney a chemical engineer
Chemical Engineering you've got a
Fulbright scholarship to MIT we dropped
out to pursue acting yeah after falling
in with Grace Jones I have always
wondered what it's been like for him
specifically in this movie to have to
like speak all of that just mumbo-jumbo
scientific nonsense when they're talking
about the key and how the dimensions
work and all that stuff he doesn't
really and and even still like the few
words they to give him their moments and
we didn't actually put him in there like
he bust down a door and says two
syllables who Joe and I I think we
settled on fan out yeah just bust down
the door goes
yeah I think he was doing parts of the
script phonetically think he was
phonetically saying a lot of arms and
grilled or almost all the like all that
stuff with the doorway all the chocolate
like this is crazy nonsense I mean would
you rather have a man who looks like
Dolph longer and then can't talk or do
you want
I don't know Val Kilmer in a totally
don't need this table all right let's
keep coming
not a he-man of words wielding his
mythical power sword
[Music]
to balances gun shoot north
some of you didn't touch on its have
similar this movie is too star-lord are
very similar 90% sure those are just
like $5 Star Wars constant man movie
leaving plenty of time for the real
stars like will door looks like they
shot Billy Barty space because he's so
disgusted score go even as a child I
found them all pudding what it looks
like he's melting I I feel like that was
though as I have I have recently been
catching up on a little bit and some of
them I watched when I was a child some
of them I'm visiting with the first time
movies like a labyrinth
yeah and legend and the Dark Crystal
they seemed I no market in this this
area of the grotesque yeah when it came
to like character design and prosper
annecy yeah fantasy stuff was more
associated with just like yeah
everything was monstrous and birth it
was intentional or where they just
figuring things out I mean I think it's
probably a little bit of both I mean
definitely was like a more you know like
Steven stuff like borman's Excalibur or
whatever were yeah like fantasy was just
grosser back then but yes it was also
that these technologies were in there is
what did that what do they young women
and of like that species look like I
don't know like it's my light zone thing
will door with a bonus yeah yeah that's
[Laughter]
the cop wounds and Harry Potter in just
a minute
cool nurses hold my cosmic this is like
attorney is somehow both like Lord of
the Rings medieval fantasy and like Star
Wars where they've got they got
computers and blasters I've been living
in castles and caves like it doesn't
that's cool it doesn't really make any
sense it's like the ready player one of
nerd culture yeah just throw it all
together right it just it feels like it
feels like all we get from of Eternia
here is like it's like cobbled together
from other movie lands yeah yeah
kind of look cool yeah steampunk quality
like a cosmic key thing but then also
everybody's got like Conan swords it's
just like a weird very useful to balance
your gun arm all right keep pull the
prosthetics Skeletor a tour de force
performance from Frank Langella who's
acting could rip the fabric of space and
time but not the fabric covering is not
Airy and of course
Julian Kevin's a small-town romance
between this orphaned waitress and an
aspiring keyboard player that for some
reason takes up 50% of my he-man movie
stop trying to teens movie he-man is for
small children and four-year-olds only
no in between not change cause act yeah
so was it just purely cost-cutting or
did or did somebody think that there was
a untapped teen romance he-man fan
market I think it's you don't have to
you don't have to outfit them in
anything special you don't have to do
action sequences you don't have to do
period anything you don't have to pay to
get people and really a lot of elaborate
makeup
yeah it's literally like shooting an
independent film drama teen film and
then every once in a while you may like
with the sword and and like some
stormtrooper shoot at and then and ho
and holds Courtney Cox for some reason
everyone keeps holding Courtney Cox in
this yeah what's weird is that you could
also make it like you could have done a
side plot about humans on earth that's
like funny and light as opposed to grim
about a grief-stricken and
guilt-stricken person like yeah I don't
know why it had to be so bleak right and
that's the thing as the movie ends on
them it's about them right no it's about
how he manifested the lives of these two
generally Julie's movies she won that
arc she's the one that has like a back
the end saves the day by being like
through his music yes that's true like
his keytar solo or whatever absolutely I
agree but I feel like
if you were going to identify like the
one protagonist of this movie I think it
would probably do delicious doom yeah
yeah halfway through love Simon like the
Battletoads figured it out okay green
light yeah it's great journey back to a
simpler time when grown man could walk
around in SL through the sky we're
probably just Japanese be a positive I
love that is there in a graveyard and
they find in a smoking crater this thing
and they're like it's a musical
instruments like yes that's exactly it
is that joke runs through so many 80s
movies that like anything baffling or
technologically like crazy or magic is
Japanese rice pops up in so many if it
even I think there's a Fawlty Towers
joke from like the mid seventies where
he thinks the moose head on the wall is
talking to her he's like oh that must be
Japanese cool trophies based on
children's toy said casual swearing what
magical hairy miniature scientists did
and vegetarianism was so rare it
literally came from another dimension
used to be an animal oh come on don't
look so shocked Tila you think he men
got a body carved out of Greece marble
by eating impossible burgers pause so
I'm sure I haven't seen it you got the
angry vegans coming after you I'm sure I
do I understand it's a joke you can't
just say it's a joke you have to believe
everything you say literally
our vegans really upset with us I'm
probably sure that they're I heard there
was somebody according to our social
media manager that they are posting
vegan bodybuilder images like hi I have
no doubt that there are many vegans and
vegetarians who are very successful
bodybuilders however it's a funny joke
to imagine a man doing that without the
chicken breast diet that Chris Hemsworth
and halibut yes it was a different world
back in the 80s they didn't have they
didn't understand of course people now
are very very built in blah blah blah
yeah I'm not denying the existence of
vegan and vegetarian bodybuilders I'm
just joking about them and it's a joke
it's possible burger by the way
delicious and the beyond burger beyond
burger is my favorite yeah yeah good
stuff yeah I'm burgers real good yeah
anyway so if you're hungry for one of
the biggest wasted opportunities and
Phil because the climax shot in total
darkness because the movie ran out of
money and the church suicides
probably that's firewheel doors mouth
barely moves at the ultimate mark of
doom promising a sequel that's never
gonna happen and after credits scene oh
yeah pause though that was to a kid
amazing yeah the concept that a movie
could be over and then at the end if you
fast forwarded that like I think I may
have been the first one in my class to
see that and I remember going to school
and being like if you Skeletor comes
back they're like you're lying I'm like
no ice well I think I was my dad works
in town
I which branded a liar because my
friends said that I was lying about the
fact that sometimes it does sound like a
lie like a lie that if I be able to make
up yeah I remember I told my friends
that if you fast food and then when the
next time we went to my friend's house
and I fast for it and they're just like
oh this idea that a movie could go on
after the credits I got insane why would
why would how could that's against the
rules you can't do that none of those
people are important about I don't know
exactly so yeah that was that was
another key moment we live in a world
now and people kids are keeps the kids a
surprise now when it doesn't happen
right no people are upset when there
isn't one yeah so if you look at that
shot it's a really it's like maybe the
coolest shot the best his mouth moves in
the really feels like they didn't nail
it until we go back and shoot the
resident globe know if it goes right now
no it's like we are at it's pretty scary
lay it is yeah it seems like to ask play
with the with the speed anyways yeah
he's like what what is this weird smoky
water under his castle whatever it's
down that chute that yeah whatever you
don't want to know
a disaster that proved you can hire the
writer of the Dark Crystal the guy who
made the music for Rock a talent all
over the florence of arabia it's
mind-blowing that VFX artist who did
Star Wars but if your producers are the
same guys who are making every man for
the same time a few weeks the party was
he'll definitely suck and break imagine
how much worse it would have been had it
not had that talent yeah they weren't
also those guys who made like if you've
seen weird low-budget ninja movies they
were those guys like American Ninja
Warrior badass for like it was all those
are all like they had the American ninja
series that is also they did break in
and break into baby awesome and if you
watch there's a documentary about them
and just how crazy everything was and
it's called electric Boogaloo right very
good
there's a very entertaining documentary
yeah check that out yeah let's finish up
this fire story list of my favorite
Robert because he did such a good job
yeah so no one told you he man's gonna
come your way we debated for a long time
about whether he Kevin is too stupid if
it should have a - I think yeah - or no
- and we decided no - I feel like this
is part of the original pitch for the
movies well he-man and Shera
and not zero he-man okay ash take not my
Orko the Crystal Skull evil Macy's
thanks for skeletons is a friend of ours
skeleton nobody was doing newton-john
elbow Cobb the authority figure from
every 80s movie and character's name I
love that his detective Bing is like
we're at an active crime scene
and this like teenagers is talking to me
and I'm gonna like leave my job to drive
him home just to prove he's crazy
getting my car I've been here for ten
minutes I've gotten all the clues that I
need we're getting in your car yet find
your girlfriend who might be a victim of
this fire instead here pumpkin I'm gonna
take care of his approach to being a
detective and his approach to being a
vice principal identical this the same
just like I'm just gonna dress you down
until I find out what I want to know
good friend slacker so I haven't begun
will door the best
I mean a lot of character names get
sanded movies but whoever gets said a
lot yeah I don't think you can do the
same thing with man-at-arms oranges
perfectly good don't put them in the
sink of your dirty sink wrappers it's
like they it's like the most
passive-aggressive product please and
the attorneys are vegetarians have
worked at Burger King yeah that's like
you got it you've already got a
restaurant setting in your movie I can
only imagine that they were shooting the
scene in the Burger King representers is
like no no you cannot just throw our
stuff away
that's the makes it look like garbage
and they're like no he's cleaning up
what other foods having them in the sink
until later when he's putting oranges in
this thing too he's just saving it for
later
just think what oranges laziest product
placement of all time yeah yeah good
stuff is good and so I think this is now
our deleted saying yes oh it was the
button yeah evylyn beast man
bubblegum next zombie mozart it's my
fault they died
plane crash those things just happened
it's like the studio's name was the only
time anyone involved cared about Canon
pause I just want to give props to you
Daniel that was a fantastic life yes
excellent joke yeah I like that joke a
lot we made steeped we may use that for
a difference none of them care about
Canon who's acting could rip the fabric
of space and time but not the fabric
covering his nostrils can we just make
Skeletor he-man story
human growth hero of a lot sigh must
bore you Nordic blond that that's next
to be we can address one of the
critiques of faint right yeah come on I
am in Australia a single reference to so
that's yeah that was sometimes we don't
know what to tell John decides I asked
John to sing it and he's like I can't do
that
not and I can't do that but he couldn't
hit he literally can't hit that's a high
note I know no one can hit that yeah gee
so yeah there you go
well Linda Perry so that was going to be
our nominal reference to the to the
route to the meme in the key meme he
mean way to beat me when people bring
that up to us a lot like why don't you
mention there's a huge meme both of this
movie but it's hard to bring it up in
the context of an honest trailer like a
reference we all [ __ ] than you on a
lot of times people say why didn't you
do X and I'm not gonna say it's because
you felt it because everybody else
thought of that joke and it's the most
obvious not that we don't do obvious
jokes a lot apparently somebody by the
power of numbskull I guess was used at
some point in a Mystery Science Theater
3000 episode cuz somebody was just like
you stole a joke precisely mm I know it
sounds like I I wrote that joke and I
didn't I it's literally one syllable
offer from the power of Grayskull and I
mean it was funny there's like dozens if
not
hundreds of Mystery Science Theater
episodes they're all two hours long like
there's a lot easier to watch steal
every joke from them they do Masters of
the Universe no I don't think so
different it was from a completely
random other miss you do a lot of like
pop culture references watching this
movie one of these days we're gonna do a
good solid class in parallel writing
this is the this is the quandary that we
find ourselves in sometimes because when
somebody says like hey why didn't you
reference X joke oftentimes if we go for
something that was the first thing we
think of then we get like you stole that
from X and the strike no we were like
well if we'll throw in like a nod to
epic rap battles or something which
you've done before
that's us saying like like a tip of the
hat to them but at the same time we have
a healthy amount of people that just
like you stole that joke I forgot I was
like no we know it's for like that's a
weird thing what I mean is it's a
Kobayashi Maru just went sometimes we
don't do what seems like the obvious
joke the unbreakable trailer this
happened cuz we did a the line and this
was this was my god Russia was like it's
called hentai and it is art which is an
office reference but like of course if
we knew we're like ripping the joke off
from the off because it doesn't make
sense if it's not right it's a reference
to my yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah this is
when we this is this is the these are
the minefields that we have to chat
sometimes yeah so you don't want to go
either one way or the easy ways there's
no way through yeah well so I said hey
poornatva yeah keep going
Flash Gordon walking the dolphin
supposed to be Eddie's ass
mold abort poor fan Cumberbatch that's
like bandit coverage to me
well not that not that shot next job
I can kind of ceasefire yet he's not
sick yeah I mean compared to Benedict
Cumberbatch you know right the celery
stock is thick yes this is Jerry it's
like it's a spell man
anyways that's why it doesn't go in I
mean he Kevin come on hey Poe will bow
Baggins
whoa Baggins discount hoggle the
sorceress supreme Elsa let her go let
her go do it for the hologram Ursa is
that Kirstie Alley
captain Eternia man-at-arms eyebrows and
half a Grauman's metric but suck they
had a lot of like arms and ons or Romans
and Kyle on poor lawns and that was like
their version of making up away good
yeah it's just make up a suffix micron
yeah yeah oh boy Skeletor has even lived
like how long until we arrived she goes
half a parsec beyond like wow parsec is
a unit of distance distance and that's
why they mess it out they start out
about less than 12 parsecs means they
have to take a shortcut not less time
yeah we got a whole movie out of it
thanks thanks great so glad that her
that happened question answered if
what's the best part of that movie yes
it Castle right that's true thank God
hey man I'm foo extreme no makeover
Burak hey girl wait that doesn't look
like my Hershel Holly blade Walker robot
job yeah we did a lot of
all the universe crawl and bones very
crawling necessary buffness snake that
one that's good not in the movie i got a
castle
I got a viewer guys clean air I got a
beautiful woman some kind of retirement
not so dudes an attorney get gifted
castles and women even if they've only
been there for like what five minutes
skeletor's right the system is corrupt
best thing to do right now is to get
3,000 miles away from Kevin my house
this town and everything just start out
fresh hey good call go to New York make
some friends see what happens I would
love that though if that were actually
Monica's backstory I moved to New York I
had a really weird experience but her
mom and friends is actually the
sorceress no yeah oh my god Wow
sorceress is is her mom in flat crystal
skeleton skull that's the same actually
[Applause]
and it's crazy so those weird crazy
cosmic I'm picturing her saying you
pulled a Monica
[Laughter]
weird record sir yeah even the backstory
for friends is terrible okay let's talk
about what you guys had to say yes
toys Most Wanted said kind of disappoint
there wasn't a Tom Paris Star Trek
Voyager joke I don't get this I don't
get that I thought of this too
there's only so much I could ask all of
you to adults the Robert Duncan MacNeil
who plays Kevin played Tom Paris on Star
Trek Voyager ok who was a crew member it
was a series regular on Star Trek
Voyager so cool for everyone yes but I
did you know jell-o was in frost/nixon
yes he played Frost why didn't we make a
frost accenture yes no but that was me
not wanting to impose all of my yeah
yeah I have not seen a lot of Star Trek
Voyager some fun ones here a Adolfo Pena
writes since he man is in topical this
video will get little views ok that's
good bizarrely I don't know how that
happened yeah I think it's funny that we
followed up the biggest movie of all
time just to stop any momentum like
there's a little bit of human momentum
in the culture right now I mean we're
getting a new movie the the toys that
made us was like a big hit documentary
Liam got to go it's not it's not the
most obscure thing we could pick yeah
Matthew Schwartz writes holy [ __ ]
Skeletor wasn't played by Jack Palance
yeah no but I don't see like it's AI
maybe if you hadn't looked at the
credits and snooker style rights Frank
Langella really wanted to dress up like
the classic toy cartoon Skeletor and
worked his butt off getting buff only to
find out they had that big black
full-body costume left that's that true
I don't think well snooker style wrote
it so style is my most trusted Frank
Langella news
like purple spin you can still see yeah
someone mentioned something about him
working out like when we were talking in
the room I don't know --gel yoked
Franklin Gillian he's in one scene in a
trench coat it was just like no I like
to work out a lot yeah that was Dan oh
he's like that chair across the room
yeah he's very he's like surprisingly
weirdly buff at what a body double now
yeah all right well tell us in the
comments who else is weirdly bummed to
tell us but is in Hollywood and join us
next week where we'll be doing an honest
trailer that oh man it's been many days
since this one that was requested but
we'll find out the one right on the
pulse of America I think enough time has
passed that we are finally ready it's
the season for this one mm-hmm so it's
an experiment yeah we'll see come back
come back next week for that it'll be
fun trust us
and we'll see you next time around
trailer commentaries bye bye
[Music]
you